[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
MAMOUN HIRZALLA: Hello.
Welcome to this
session, which we
will be talking about
migrating apps to the cloud.
And we have a question to you,
that's systematic or random?
And my name is Mamoun Hirzalla.
I am a principal cloud architect
with Accenture's Google Center
of Excellence.
And I'll be joined with my
colleague, Greg Buxkemper, who
will be talking to
us also through parts
of the presentation, an
important one as well.
So let me spend a minute, talk
about the session overview,
and what we're
trying to accomplish
as part of the session.
The first part that we
are going to talk about
is talk about the business
priorities and challenges
with migrating
apps to the cloud,
and talk about what do you
need to do when you start
this journey of
migrating your existing
workloads from either
on-prem or existing cloud
provider to Google.
And then, as part
of this process,
Greg will walk us through
Accenture's approach
for the cloud migration.
So that would be the
first part that we
spend on this
particular presentation.
Then I'll take the presentation
and talk specifically
about what are the tools
and the best practices
that we do as part of
specifically moving
these workloads into
Google Cloud Platform.
And then, on the third part,
we will spend some time
talking about some
experiences and sharing
some lessons learned from
existing client examples
that we have helped in
migrating to the cloud.
So with that in mind, I'll hand
it over to my colleague here,
and who will walk you
through the first part
of the presentation
GREG BUXKEMPER:
Hi, good morning.
My name is Greg Buxkemper.
I'm one of the leaders
in Accenture's journey
to cloud practice.
And that's really our
vendor agnostic component.
And so you'll hear me talk
a lot more about process
and methodologies
while Mamoun is
going to talk about specific
examples and technologies.
So when our clients start to
talk about moving to cloud,
there's this temptation that we
see of clients looking to say,
there's all kinds of technical
problems, technical debt,
and issues that I need
to resolve before I move.
And when I'm move
to cloud, I want
to take advantage,
full advantage
of all of the
capabilities and features
that cloud has to offer.
And what we see is that
can lead to problems.
So as an example,
one of my clients,
which is an oil and
gas conglomerate,
basically, they looked at their
environment, and they said,
we need to fix all of our
Active Directory issues.
We need to fix several
security issues.
And we want to take
all of our applications
to PaaS, cloudify everything.
And about two,
two and half years
later, they basically have
nothing to show for it,
because they're just stuck.
So in that case,
greed is not good.
When we start to
think about planning,
We have to look at the ideal
situation and the situation
in the real world.
And in the ideal situation,
every application
would be fully standalone.
The application stack
So you have an isolated
application server, web server,
database server, I
mean, no interaction.
And then even if you
peel away the technology,
the user communities would
be completely separate,
there'd be no interaction.
You had no interaction
or no conflicts
with other business priorities
or other initiatives.
But we all know
that's not the case.
So the reality of the
situation is everything
that we all work on is
very much intertwined.
You have shared
database servers.
You have shared web farms.
You have application
teams that are
focused on several priorities
across different applications.
And you have to work
around those things.
Those are all
things that we have
to address when we're thinking
about migration planning.
So if we talk about
planning, it's
really not a binary situation.
It really is a spectrum.
And on the far left-hand
bookend of that,
you really have this concept of
just throw stuff on the truck
and move it.
And that's really--
you walk in the door,
you grab a few things, or you
grab your entire portfolio
of applications and
servers, and you move it,
and then you just
see what happens.
And what we see-- we actually
do have some clients that
try to do this on their own.
And what we see
that happens is they
don't understand the impacts.
They experience major
issues during the migration,
problems with latency, problems
with application and GUI
performance.
And ultimately, their
migration loses momentum,
because they lose the support
of the business and the user
community.
On the other end of
the spectrum is really
the scientific approach.
And it's this concept of
must understand everything
about the applications and the
servers before you move them.
And quite frankly,
that's just as
bad as the concept of throw
everything on the truck,
because you can really get stuck
in that analysis-paralysis mode
and not want to move until
you have perfect information.
And so the goal is to find
somewhere in between that suits
your organization and
your migration approach.
One of the next things
that we need to talk about,
as we look at
migration planning,
is what are your business
drivers for migrating to cloud?
When we first started migrating
to cloud a few years ago,
really the drivers
were all around
these concepts of cost
savings and efficiency,
get things into the
cloud where we can
size for average utilization.
We don't have to size for peak.
Start to make use of that
as-a-service capability,
turn things off
and on as needed.
But now, as we look
into cloud, there's
many more business
drivers and values
that you can get out
of that, the IT agility
and the innovation, and,
ultimately, the business
growth and business agility.
So we're moving beyond IT
cost to IT generating revenue,
to really cloud-driving
business revenue.
And you have to take
that into account
as you do your planning.
And one example to
think about that
is a retail client that we had.
Originally, they had started
to look at cost savings.
That was their primary driver.
But when they got
into it, they realized
they could start to take
advantage of the analytics
and machine learning
capabilities
and really immediately jump to
getting this business growth
and business agility.
So again, those are
some of the factors
you need to think about.
So you'll hear us talk
about the different steps
and the different
data points that we
think you need to collect when
you doing migration planning.
And planning, really,
to a lot of people,
is all about, what date are
we going to migrate things?
And we would argue that you also
need to think about how are you
going to migrate it?
What approach are
you going to take?
And really don't think
about that as one approach
for your entire migration.
Think about that on a
per application basis.
So there's really
a ladder or a curve
here of effort versus benefit.
And the first adoption
or migration method
is really this concept of
data center consolidation
or basic capabilities.
And this would be moving
applications and servers
primarily to consolidate
your data centers.
You'll hear people moving to
cloud just the DR environment.
Or you may hear them move
content to part of the content
delivery network in
order to take off
some of the capacity out of
their existing structure.
The next step up in
that is to just do
IaaS lift-and-shift migration.
So just take your
existing applications,
with minimal configuration
changes and adjustments,
and move them into cloud as is.
And then you
continue to ramp up,
and you get into a little
bit of transformation,
moving to containers and
other technologies like that.
Or you can do full-blown
transformation
and really recode or
refactor your application
and take full advantage
of all of the features
and capabilities that
cloud has to offer.
And like I said, one of the
things to think about here
is that each application, you
can really pick and choose
here.
If you have an application
that is not maintained but is
heavily used for certain
periods of the month,
that really makes sense from
a lift-and-shift perspective.
You're not going to
get a lot of benefit
out of refactoring and
recoding that application.
Whereas, on the far other
end of the spectrum,
if you have an
application that's
driving a lot of business,
there's a lot of data coming,
going, it's very actively
developed, that's
going to make a lot of sense
to think about a transformation
approach and go
through the effort
and work to transform
that application
and recode it from
scratch, potentially
So as we start to talk
about migration methodology,
there's really four
challenges, that we're
trying to overcome in
the migration, when
we think about planning.
The first is understanding
the inventory.
A lot of people
struggle to understand,
what are all of the servers
they have in their environment?
What are all of the
applications that they
have in their environment?
And then that really leads us
into the next step, which is--
sorry, the next challenge,
which is understanding
the dependencies between those.
Which applications
use which servers?
Which ones are divided out into
your different environments
between your non-production and
your production environments?
And then probably
more importantly,
for migration and dealing with
some of the additional network
latency that we take on
when we move to cloud,
is understanding these
application-to-application
interfaces.
So when you move
one application,
what's the impact going to be
to the end user experience?
And is the application still
going to be functional?
And then, on the
back end, what's
the impact of batching
those kind of things?
The third challenge there
is around optimizing
these repeated efforts.
If you're moving more than
a few hundred servers,
there's a script or
a process that you're
going to want to follow.
And that's one of
the reasons we talk
about these different
migration patterns.
And you want to be as efficient
in that process as possible
and have the same
script that you're
executing, over and over.
You don't want every
migration to be
a snowflake that you have to
figure things out every time.
And the last piece that
we're-- or last challenge that
we're trying to address
in planning is really
understanding your
resourcing needs.
Every organization that I know
of is resource-constrained.
And you have to figure out
how to work through that.
And how you do that is--
one of the ways that you address
that is with proper planning
and laying that out, laying
out your different move
types across your
schedule, so that you
can predict what your resource
requirements are going to be.
One of the reasons that we like
our methodology for planning
these migrations
is that we really
take a business-driven
approach to this.
So you'll hear of
some migrations
being very server-centric.
They talk in, and they'll
just pick up some servers
and move them.
And I would argue that's
a recipe for disaster.
That's going to cause
problems, straightaway.
If you walk in, and you begin
working with the business
and then go downward,
top down, you
should see a lot
more success when
you're doing your planning.
So you start by talking
with the business,
understanding which business
units want to migrate,
make sure they understand
the value of that.
And then naturally,
you should start
to see business units that are
early adopters or groups even
within business units
that are early adopters,
and some business units that
want to migrate later or last.
From there, then you
can start to dive
into their applications,
the different environments,
get to your servers and
your shared infrastructure.
So this is really the guts of
our migration planning process.
And-- whoops-- there we go.
So it starts on
the left-hand side,
and that's with understanding
your application inventory.
And I think it's
probably well understood
that you need to understand
what all the applications are
in your environment,
and you need to
from a technology perspective.
But you'll also
benefit if you'll
start to understand
also the business
view of the application.
When is it used?
How is it used?
How many users?
Components like security.
If you do have a little
bit of technical debt
that you want to
address, understanding
those kind of components.
And then the same situation
on the infrastructure side.
What are all of those
servers in your environment?
What operating system
are they running?
What operating
system-- and that's
particularly if the OS is not
supported in your future state
environment, or you want to
use the opportunity to upgrade,
but collecting that
kind of information.
From there, then you're
starting to build
that mapping or those
linkages between the servers
and the applications.
And again, that's both
the application-to-server,
which is one part of it.
But probably the
more important part
of that and the
more difficult part
is that
application-to-application
mapping.
You have to understand
those interfaces
so that when you pick
them up and move them,
you move the highly-coupled
applications together,
at the same time, and maintain
that end user usability.
So then once you map
those infrastructure
to applications and
applications to applications,
then you need to go through the
process of identifying the move
approach.
And it's back to determining
which of those applications
are going to get the value
of cloud and to what extent.
So if you want to assign
the IaaS lift-and-shift,
if you want to do--
or refactoring, or
containerization,
you need to do all of
that thinking, or at least
an initial pass, during the
migration planning phase.
Then, once you have that
mapping and that move approach,
you take that mapping and you
use that to create your bundles
or move groups.
And in our
methodology, the bundle
is really the atomic
unit or the smallest unit
of applications and servers
that can move at the same time.
So you know that,
as you're talking
about doing a move, that
bundle, that group of servers
and applications, all
has to move together.
And if there's a problem, it
all will move back together.
And likewise, when you start
to think about waves, to us,
a wave is just a date.
So a wave is a collection
of bundles on a date.
So then once you have that
bundle, or those atomic units
of servers and applications that
need to move at the same time
to preserve that
end user experience,
then you can put
them on the schedule.
And that schedule really
starts with a straw man
or a framework of what are
your possible move dates.
And typically, we see
certain dates fall out
because of month
end fiscal close,
freeze periods having to
do with either busiest
times of the year or
with holiday seasons.
You could also start to see
components of the schedule
fall out for particular business
units or particular application
teams because of other
campaigns or other initiatives
they have going on.
But that's where you place those
bundles on those move dates.
And then once you have that, you
have a fairly robust schedule,
at that point, that you can
use for resource estimation
and those kinds of things.
So how we handle this from
an Accenture standpoint
is we actually have built,
instantiated our methodology
into a tool called
Accelerate for Cloud.
And Accelerate for Cloud
really is a workflow tool.
When we looked at the
tooling environment-- so
there's a lot of
great tools out there
to drive these migrations.
But they're technical tools.
They're good tools
for taking the servers
and the applications and
getting them up into the cloud.
There's not really
a lot of good tools
to drive the work
behind the migration
and drive all the tasks.
And so we have this tool
called Accelerate for Cloud.
And it takes us all the way
from that inventory stage,
where you load in the inventory,
and then you start to match
and map it.
It takes us through an
application questionnaire
process, where we ask the--
we load it up with
information from a CMDB,
other spreadsheets, and
any other data sources that
are possible, and then that gets
passed back to the application
owners to validate
that information
and plug-in other things that
we need for the migration.
And then, from there, we can
use that to drive the schedule.
We use it to check our bundles.
So it actually keeps
track of all the mappings
that we've identified
and the interfaces
between applications.
And then we can use that
to validate and make sure
that we've accommodated all
those interfaces as we're
putting the bundles together.
And then it turns out
a number of reports
that allows us to take reports
back to the business and say,
here's when all of your
applications are migrating.
Go to individual owners and
say, here's the different events
that you'll have.
Is that good or bad based on
your scenario and situation?
And then, ultimately,
it drives through
to the final migration,
which is beyond planning.
But it gets us down into
15-minute increments
during the actual
migration where
we can track the migration of
hundreds of servers at a time.
MAMOUN HIRZALLA: Thanks Greg.
GREG BUXKEMPER: Thank you.
MAMOUN HIRZALLA: Can
you hear me guys?
OK, great.
So that was an important part
of the migration that usually
gets forgotten in many small and
medium type of companies, who
may think that just because I
can take an image or a server
and move it to Google Cloud
Platform, that basically means
the majority of my job is done.
And reality is far,
far, far from that.
And I'm going to start looking
at some of the more details.
So Greg gave you the
20,000-foot view.
I'm going now down to about the
1,000-foot view to talk about
how we can do some
of this in GCP,
and what are the implications,
and the things that you need
to be aware of, and what type
of some of the adoption patterns
that we see as we talk to
our customers in the field.
So, there are customers
who would basically
still insist on the fact that we
still want to do it on our own.
And for those who are insisting
to do it on their own,
basically all the things
that Greg talked about,
whether that's the
planning, figuring out
the inventory, the mapping, the
bundling, the scheduling, all
of that, that basically
goes back to your lap.
And if you were to look at
these type of activities
here, whether it's assessment,
planning, or the networking
scheduling, or the
application, or whatever
additional activities
that you need
to do, you need to take a deep
look, within your organization,
and say, do I have the
capability, the skills,
the time, and willing
to assume the risk
if I were to do that on my own?
So that's a key
question you need
to think about as
part of your taking
that upon yourself to go
and do it from A to Z. So
that's just something to point
out, because there are still
these folks out in the field
that they think they can do it
from A to Z on their
own, without looking
at it from a holistic
type of perspectives
and understanding what are
the implications of the app
migration type of process.
Now, if you were to look
at where Google can help.
I'm sure many of you have looked
at the Google Cloud Platform,
and that's why you're here
trying to look at, well,
what are the tools, the things
that would help me as part
of the migration process.
So if you were to
look at this slide
basically it represents
different consumption models
and the things that are the
typical suspects for migrating
to the cloud.
So when you look at
Infrastructure-as-a-Service
platform, as a service in SaaS,
different companies would be
at different end
of the spectrum.
And some companies may be
at all ends of the spectrum
when it comes to these
type of consumption models.
So from Google's perspective,
we have different type
of constructs or
capabilities that
would allow you to say,
OK, well in terms of SaaS,
one of the key things
that we look at
is Google Cloud Storage.
And that's one that we
want to basically just try
to get our data
on it, start doing
some backups, disaster
recovery, and all
of these type of things.
PaaS perspective, we
have lots of constructs
that would help you to
get there as well in terms
of the data that would be
required to be migrated
with these type of apps.
And these are some
of the constructs,
whether it's CloudSQL,
Datastore BigTable, BigQuery,
Spanner, it doesn't matter.
All of these things
are managed for you.
And they can be used as
part of the migration.
And if you're looking
to import or export data
from SaaS type of
applications, you
can leverage the
services of Dataflow that
would allow you to do that.
From application
perspective, you
have different set
of options, as well.
So if you're starting
with IaaS, you
have compute type
of capabilities
with GCE, Google Compute
Engine type of capabilities.
And you have also the ability
to leverage containers
as part of the process.
And then you also have,
from PaaS perspective,
if you don't want to go
and fiddle with that,
you can look at it
and say, OK, well,
I want to have the
ability to just not worry
about that and leverage
things that are already
procured for me.
And that's where you
leverage Google App Engine.
And Kubernetes comes
somewhere in between the two.
And certainly, Apigee
comes into the picture,
because, if you want
to monetize or provide
these type of API interfaces
to your applications,
that's where Apigee can
be part of the process.
Now, what are the migrations
that we see in the field
when it comes to GCP?
Let's start with a simple case.
The simplest of cases
is Google Cloud Storage.
So this is basically
somebody that's
trying to do a backup
disaster recovery.
Or somebody may have
a static website
that only contains,
in this point, just
HTML and some JavaScript that
basically what you can do,
you can just migrate all your
content into Google Cloud
Storage.
It's global.
It's replicated.
Content is accessible
through URI.
You can point a DNS to it.
The whole website can be
up and running in minutes.
So that's something
that you can do.
If you want to leverage CDNs,
you can also look at the ones
that Google has
partnered with that
makes it even more faster
type of access to it
and caching at the
edge of the network.
If you are saying, well, OK,
that's too simple for me.
I have more complex stuff.
And that's where you can start
looking at the Google Compute
Engine.
And we start looking at, well,
what type of raw capabilities
and power that Google Cloud
Platform brings to the table?
So that's where
you start looking
at different type of machines
that are available to you,
whether it's Linux, Windows,
and live migration from Google
as part of the process.
Or you can look
at it from I have
standard machines that
are available to you
out of the box.
I need something that's
completely different
because I'm special.
You can still go
and do that, create
the amount of CPUs
and RAM for you
and the storage that
caters to your needs
rather than using what
Google offers out of the box.
You can have the ability
to create custom images.
And you can take snapshots.
You can make these snapshots
available to other people
in different projects.
You can also create or deploy a
container image as part of GCE.
So if you have built
your containers,
you can deploy them
directly on VMs from Google
as part of the process.
And you have the ability
to procure up to 160 cores.
I just checked
that in the console
to see what's the maximum,
because that number changes.
So you have up to 160 cores,
four terabytes of RAM,
and up to 64
terabytes of storage
that are available to you.
And on top of all of that,
you get all the benefits
of elastic type of capabilities
autoscale up, autoscale down,
monitoring, all of
these things that you
get as part of Google
Cloud Platform.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
you might come and say, you know
what, I don't have the patience
to deal with all of this.
I want something
that's much easier.
I just want my developer's to
go give me a Java environment,
and they just want
to start coding.
I don't want to fiddle with
IaaS and do any of this machine
setup or any of that.
Great.
So that's where
Google App Engine
comes into the picture
as part of the process.
You have two flavors
of Google App Engine.
You have the Flex and Standard.
Standard, pretty much the same.
They're both fully-managed
type of environments.
They're autoscaling their
version as part of the process.
Flex gives you more capabilities
than what Standard offers.
Standard offers four languages.
Flex offers you four
plus two and any type
of language environment
that you want to add,
because you can incorporate
those as part of your process.
You have the ability to do the--
all of these type
of environments
are backed up for you
using the Datastore, SQL,
or GCS Cloud Storage that
are available out of the box.
They autoscale to zero
for the standard part.
So basically you
can use it for free.
If you build it up,
and nobody's using it,
you don't have to pay for it.
For the Flex, it
scales down to one.
So somebody would have to pay
for that if nobody's using it.
And Flex also gives you
additional capabilities
like root access if you
want to, where you don't
have that as part of standard.
And if you're coming and
saying, well, that's great,
but I'm a company who is running
significant type of workloads
that are running on my
on-prem, and they're
taking a significant amount
of time to be processed.
Can Google help me with that?
Of course they can.
And that's where we start doing
the burst out type of mode
and hybrid type of
clouds where you
can provide some connectivity
between you and Google.
There are many options.
You can do VPN, direct,
interconnect, peering.
And you can use the
Google Cloud power
to get some of this type of
workloads move to the cloud,
let them run.
When you're done,
they scale down,
and you don't pay for additional
work that you don't have to.
And you don't have to procure
any of the infrastructure.
Or you're on-prem, and you
don't have to worry about that.
OK, now I procured all
this infrastructure,
nobody's using it.
So that's a good option
for those type of companies
who may be interested
in that entry point
as part of Google
Cloud Platform.
So there are many
options for you.
Look at your potential
use cases, what
you want to do out
of that, and select
the right pattern for you.
And look at it from a
holistic perspective, as well.
And you can look at it from
a tactical perspective,
if that is the
only thing that you
want to look at, and
continue with that.
Now, as we look at GCP migration
and type of objectives,
there are many stations
along the way where
customers look at it
and say, well, OK,
my objective, from
moving to the cloud,
is really about I want to
have my dev environment
or my whole infrastructure
on Google Cloud,
because I think it's the
right platform for me from dev
testing and production.
That would be one option for
customers looking into it.
Other customers
may come and say,
you know what, I
just want to use it
for disaster recovery backup.
Or others saying we heard
that you have great tools
and capabilities around big
data and machine learning,
and that becomes the
primary objective
of moving to the cloud.
So it really all depends on you,
what you want to do with it.
But for this particular
example, that I'm
trying to explain
here, this is a company
whose primary objective
was to accelerate
app delivery and leverage Google
Cloud Platform to do that.
And what type of capabilities
that Google offers to you
in this type of realm?
So I talked about the GCE type
of components and the fact
that we have GKE as well
in terms of Kubernetes,
and the fact that we have
these wonderful clusters
that Kubernetes can allow you
to spin and scale up and scale
down automatically.
You have also the ability
for the Container Builder.
So if you want to build
containers on GCP,
you have the ability to do that.
And if you don't want
to use Docker Hub,
you have an alternative
that is provided
to you through the Container
Registry on Google Cloud
Platform.
You have the ability
to leverage App Engine
as part of the process.
And just announced,
the Cloud Build
is also one of these tools
that you can use and look
into as part of the arsenal
for building or accelerating
your app delivery on the cloud.
You can also have the ability
to import VMs, take snapshots,
images, and do anything
you want to with that,
plus the availability of all
these container-optimized
operating systems that
are available to you
out of the box from Google.
Other customers who
may come look at it
and say, OK, well my destination
is really machine learning
and AI, because there
are many things that
would be beneficial to me
from my particular use case.
And with machine
learning and AI,
I think one of the key things
just to remember and keep
in mind is to sort
the hype from facts.
And the first thing
you need to do,
whether it's Google Cloud
Platform or any other type
of cloud provider,
is to understand
what are the real use cases that
you're trying to accomplish.
Lots of companies
right now are saying
we want to do machine
learning and AI without fully
understanding what
does that mean
or without fully selecting
the right use cases
and having the
right data in order
to get to machine learning.
So once you put that aside,
you have the right data,
you have the right use cases,
you've done your homework, now
what Google Cloud Platform
can help me as part of that--
and we have tons
of capabilities--
but it all starts
with the basics.
The basic is basically getting
your data to Google Cloud.
And we have lots of tools,
from Google Perspective,
that allows me to cater to a
structured, non-structured type
of data, allow me to cater to
LTP or all app type of loads.
So it really depends on you,
what is the right platform
or construct for you to get
the data to Google Cloud.
Once you make these
type of decisions,
you start looking at
what type of tools
that are available
to me in terms of,
I want to use the
Google Transfer Service,
or I want to use
gsutil, or I want
to use any of these
providers that
offer the transfer
type of capabilities
to me as part of the process.
So there are many
options to you.
And in previous session, I
talked about these options
in detail, and data
migration to cloud.
It's a whole session about that,
so can not cover all of it.
But these are part
of the key decisions
that you need to
make as you start
in this particular journey
to machine learning.
And then you also
have the ability
to do the cloud native
support for Hadoop.
And that's in the
form of Dataproc.
And they just announced
the autoscaling
of Dataproc clusters, which
is a great thing to do.
It's in beta right now,
but it soon will be in GA.
And that would allow you
to automatically scale up,
scale down in these
type of clusters
as you move your Hadoop
workloads into Google Cloud
Platform.
And then we have the
best-of-breed analytics
and machine learning.
TensorFlow is the number
one adopted open source
tool for machine learning.
It's open source by
Google, so it has been
used in Google for a long time.
It's the number one adopted.
And we have the pre-built
models, the perception APIs,
and AutoML type of capabilities
that are available to you.
Plus from exploration
and analysis,
you have the Data Studio, the
Datalabs, and Google Analytics
360 that are part of
the mix of the tools
that you need to look
into as you migrate
or your destination becomes
the machine learning.
Now, a question that
always comes up,
as I move to the cloud,
lots of companies
or lots of individuals
think that re-architecting
is one of those
sexy things that I
have to have when I
migrate to the cloud.
And the answer is
not necessarily true,
because there are lots of
statistics that show that there
is value in lift-and-shift.
So I really don't have to just
re-architect my applications
to the cloud to gain the
benefits of the cloud.
There are cases where
it makes a lot of sense
to go and re-architect the
whole application or portions
of the application
so that you could
leverage these type of things.
But I think one
of the key things
that you need to look at,
am I, as an organization,
equipped with the
right tools and skills
to take on such an endeavor?
So re-architecting and going
into microservice's pattern
and all that stuff, and
the impact on DevOps,
and how you go from regular
monolith type of systems
into suddenly
microservices, and how
that impacts the
whole organization
is not a trivial one.
So you need to be really aware
of the implications of doing
that.
And once you cross that barrier,
then yes, re-architecting
could be a great thing to
do, for the right use cases,
for the right situations.
In this type of example
that I show here,
this happens to be
an insurance company.
They had a great algorithm
for underwriting risk.
However, that algorithm was
not taking into consideration
some of the
additional data that's
coming from different sources.
And they wanted to
do something with it.
So what to do with that?
So they said, OK, there
are certain pieces that
can be refactored, where we
can start looking at that data,
incorporate it, and then
I can create an API so
that other components of the
business could leverage that,
a new type of functionality.
And re-architecting made sense
in this particular example.
So it really depends
on your situation.
Now a question comes up also
with the GCP migration tools
from Google.
What's out of the box for me?
If you were to go to
a project in Google,
and you look at
import VM, you will
be provided with two options,
Cloud Endure and Velostrata.
May 2018, just about
two months ago, Google
announced that they're
acquiring Velostrata,
and it would become
a Google company
in the coming month or so.
There are many
sessions on Velostrata,
but the primary differentiator
between the two, Cloud Endure
is a block-level
type of migration.
So if you have an application
with 10 terabytes, 100
terabytes, it's a
block-level migration.
That means the whole thing
needs to be migrated,
and it cannot be operated
until everything gets migrated
to the cloud.
Velostrata, on the other hand,
allows you to split the storage
from compute.
And it migrates the
compute to the cloud.
And it allows you to
execute on the compute part
while it reaches out
to the data that's
still in the on-prem
type of situation.
And then silently,
it migrates the data,
streams it into the cloud.
And if something goes
wrong, you can roll it back,
and it stays where it is.
So it's a pretty neat type of
concept as part of the process.
On average, it's about 10
minutes for migrating images.
There is an example, on
YouTube where they migrate
SugarCRM in about 11 minutes.
And it's pretty impressive.
Now, I'll just go
back and remind you
of what Greg mentioned earlier.
Greed is not good, because you
can come and say, OK, well,
if it's that easy, let's
go on start migrating.
No, the answer is not that.
I'm not trying to say that,
yes, it's easy and nice,
but all the things that
Greg have talked about,
the dependencies, the
infrastructure, all of that,
and here are things
that you need to look
at as part of your migration.
As you start, where
are these VMs going?
What is my project's structure?
Am I creating one project,
multiple projects, 10 projects?
What am I doing about my network
and VPC and IP management?
Is that happening on its own,
or is somebody doing it for me?
What are my DevOps practices?
How my developers
and engineers are
going to do when these images
are suddenly backing up?
And how do I get images?
Where do I store them?
All of these things
are important.
Identity and access management,
are you creating the groups?
What type of groups?
What type of roles?
Moving from on-prem to
a cloud type of model,
are there any things
that you need to do?
Certainly, yes.
And then you have to look at
from a security perspective,
firewall roles, routes, et
cetera, what's happening there?
What ports do you need to open?
Which applications are talking
through which applications?
And finally, who is going
to manage all of that?
Are you going to leverage
Stackdriver, in what capacity?
What are you going
to do with the logs?
What type of dashboard
things, intelligence
that you are going
to glean out of that?
I'm not trying to
make it very hard.
But I'm just giving you a
dose of reality in terms of,
when you migrate, there
are many considerations
to consider as part
of the process.
And all the things that
Greg have talked about,
that's the prep work that needs
to happen before you start
putting and importing that VM.
Certainty you need
to start with a POC.
Start in baby steps.
See how the process works.
Get some comfort level
as part of the process.
And then you can look at a
much grander type of journey
into migrating
process down the road.
So with that, I'll hand it
back over to my colleague,
Greg, who will walk
you through an example.
Then I'll finish the
last two examples.
Thank you.
GREG BUXKEMPER: Thank you.
So as we look at some of
these client examples,
we talked about some of
the questions you'd ask.
And I think the technical
questions are all
pretty apparent to us.
But we would also
recommend you think
about a different line
of questioning around
some business questions and
really some project management
type questions.
And I think you'll see
how these played out
in the client examples that
we're going to go through.
But first and foremost, to
shape your migration plan
and how you approach
planning, you
should talk to the
IT and business
on what are the primary
reasons for moving to cloud?
Is it just cost
savings, or are you
trying to get some of
that additional agility,
and innovation, and
business growth out of that?
And what are the
expected outcomes?
Again, those questions are going
to drive some overall themes
and help you understand
if your plan is
going to accomplish those.
And then, from a project
management perspective,
you really want to think
about, how fast are
you wanting to move to cloud?
What does that mean from a pace?
So if you want to be
done in six months
and you have 2,000
servers, can you actually
do that many
servers every month?
Do you have the
capacity to do that?
Or do you need to look at
changing some factor there?
What's the budget?
If your plan comes
back and tells you
that it's all
refactoring, and you
know it's going to
take you thousands
of hours per
application, you probably
don't have the right plan.
And then the other--
the last couple,
they're just going
to tie into those.
So the first client
example here is
it's a leading marketer and
distributor of beverages.
And this is an organization
that had about 1,000 servers.
It was a mix of Windows as
well as some proprietary AIX
and an iSeries that
drove a significant part
of the business process.
And from a business
perspective, they
were looking to get away
from their heavy assets.
And they were looking
to offload everything,
from their data center
to bottling plants,
and really shut
down some capability
within this one
particular business unit.
And so how that played out
into their migration plan
is it ended up being basically
a lift-and-shift migration
of about 500 servers, just
a regular IaaS migration.
But then they looked at
those proprietary platforms.
And for the AIX, they
did the business case,
and they said that's
worth transforming.
So they didn't have
to pay AIX and some
of the middleware service
charges going forward.
And so they moved about
100, 150 servers that way.
And then they looked
at the iSeries.
And we looked at a couple
of different things
to do with that.
And ultimately they
said, it's too important.
And we don't want to invest
a lot of money in this.
And so they kept that
separate and in a colo.
And then, as you would
expect, in any time
you're going through a
large transformation, about
200 servers, they just fell
off because of de-commissioning
and not being used anymore.
So while overall
it was a success,
and we did a significant
amount of planning,
there were some lessons
to be learned here.
And this is the initial
migration plan and then
the actual migration plan as
it went through evolutions.
And so you can see
that red dashed line
on the left-hand side, that was
the original migration plan.
And then in
parallel, the company
was executing an SAP
move to cloud, as well,
and ran into some
problems there.
That sucked up
resources that we needed
to use for the
non-SAP migration.
And so that shifted out.
Now, the interesting
thing here is,
while we did have to replan,
because we had collected
all of the constraint
information
and some of the other business
and project management
information when
we did the plan,
we were able to replan in the
course of just a few days,
take that back to the business
and application team, say,
does this work for you?
They signed off, and then
we started to execute again.
And then you'll see that we then
had to replan one more time.
The other thing
that was going on
is they were shifting
their network management
to another provider.
And that ended up
causing some problems
with the network
delays and connections
and those kind of things.
And again, we had to go
back to the drawing board,
but we were able to do that
very quickly, because we already
had all the data
collected and were
able to lay that out again.
So one of our arguments
here is, certainly, you
need to do pretty good planning.
But at a certain
point, you won't
have control over some of
the parallel initiatives.
And you're going
to get influenced.
But if you're
planning data is good,
if you collected the
right information,
you can adjust and pivot
to that very quickly.
MAMOUN HIRZALLA: Thank you.
So let's walk through
our second example.
And that's a financial and
health care services company.
And that company,
basically they wanted
to migrate a certain number of
applications for a conference.
And they wanted to do it fast.
So it's right from the get
go, do this quickly right.
And the assumption is we have
done the homework around which
applications we want to
migrate, because these
are the ones that we needed.
And the candidates
were provided to us.
As part of this process,
you need to look at it
and say, OK, well, are these the
right applications before you
start the migration process.
Because, yes, the customer
may come and tell you,
these are the applications
that I want to migrate.
One of the key
things that you need
to ask, what are
the dependencies?
Are these applications
a standalone?
Can they function on their own?
Are there other dependencies
that you can-- so if I
go and flip the
switch, from A to Z,
and then these applications,
once they go to the cloud,
is that OK, or are
there other things
that I need to worry about?
Turned out that one
of these applications
was not the right
application to migrate,
because there were
lots of dependencies
that they were not aware of.
So even though the
customer is the one who
recommended what type of
application to migrate,
they were not aware of 100%
of these type of dependencies.
And that's very common.
It's not every company
that know everything.
There are lots of people who
know or write this application
without even documentations
and doing something
that you may not be aware of.
So just pay attention to
that as part of the process.
So what we did, we
ended up doing--
we designed the right
secure architecture for them
in Google Cloud Platform.
We did our due diligence when it
comes to these of applications,
and we selected the right
metaphors from Google
to migrate them.
And the applications
were migrated.
And the project was a success.
From key lessons
learned perspective
is trying to understand what
type of workloads, in general.
So I'm going to talk,
in general here,
about workload prioritization.
So some companies may
come and tell you, well,
what is the criteria for
workload prioritization?
Some companies may approach
it from TPS per second,
Transactions Per Second.
So the more TPS per second,
most likely that application
is more of a mission critical.
And that becomes a less
likelihood candidate
that you need to migrate first.
So that's one of those
things that you probably
want to put towards the middle
or the bottom of the list,
because depending on the machine
criticality, if something
goes wrong, business
may be disrupted.
So you may want to start with
the ones that are more simple,
the ones that has less
interfaces, the ones that
may not impact the business
in a significant manner.
Analytical workloads
are typically
one of these workloads that you
can prioritize to the cloud.
Because, what you
can do with that,
you can learn a lot from moving
these types of applications
to the cloud and seeing
what type of lessons learned
and what type of skills
you have in place,
so that you can adjust for
the next mission-critical type
of migrations as
part of the process.
The other lessons
learned is skills.
I think if you are
in the job market
and looking for somebody
who knows Google Cloud
Platform very well,
you don't find
many of these people
in the marketplace.
That is something that a lot
of companies, that we know of,
are struggling.
And that is something that
you need to pay attention
to as you put your
scheduling plan
and who is the right
partner that you
need to work with as part
of the migration process.
The next example
that I'll talk about,
it's a large global bank.
Basically, that bank
operates in North America
and has a global presence.
The problem statement
was they wanted
to migrate a risk
application that
was taking about five
hours to process,
but significant amount of
cost that is being spent
on the horsepower that is
required to go and figure out
all this type of risk and
all of these calculations
that needed to happen.
So as part of the process,
we looked at the application.
We looked at the
existing components.
We had all the time to do that.
So I'll emphasize that.
Because there were
elements of re-architecture
or re-architecting some
components of the application.
So we had all the time that
we needed to look at it,
investigate, and
figure out, OK, here
are certain components
of refactoring
that would be required.
Looking at the cost that's
being generated or created,
we looked at a construct
in Google Cloud Platform
that's called Preemptible VMs.
Anybody heard about
Preemptible VMs?
OK, very few.
Preemptible VMs are among those
key wonderful things in Google
Cloud where, if your application
is not mission critical,
you basically procure
a VM and you say,
I want that to be preemptible.
What does that mean?
Google would schedule
that for you.
It would run.
But if Google needs that
capacity for that VM,
on a one-minute notice,
they'll take it away,
they'll park
everything, and then
when they're done with
that, they'll restart it,
and it will resume.
What do you get in
return for that?
About 80% discount on
the cost of the VM.
So that's pretty significant.
So if you have
these workloads that
do not need to be
on all the time,
and you can leverage preemptible
VMs, sure, all power to you.
This client saved a significant
amount of cost, 70% of the cost
was saved by using
preemptible VMs.
And we also were
able to re-architect
some of these applications and
use the microservice pattern
as part of the process.
But one of the key lessons
learned for the customer here
is they did not have enough
people with the right skills
in DevOps.
And that's where the
partner came in and provided
our own methodology
when it comes
to how you could use
these type of patterns
within your organization, what
type of assessment that would
be needed, what type
of gaps, and what
type of recommendations to
fill these gaps were provided.
And pretty much, it turned out
to be a very successful story
at the end of the day.
So the last thing that--
the question we asked
at the beginning
of the session, anybody still
thinks that it's a random job?
OK, good, no hands showing.
I'll just leave you with this.
This is just one comment,
from Dimensional Research,
why our application
migration products are
late and over budget.
Basically, the statistics and
the survey that they have done,
they found that, yes, there is
value in moving to the cloud.
Lots of companies,
who move to the cloud,
were able to achieve the
benefit of the cloud.
But the key statement
that they found
that initial projects
were more difficult than
expected, taking a year or more.
Some of them are failing.
75% of these
projects took longer.
50% of the participants revealed
that they are over budget.
So the key things
that were basically
uncovered as a reason for that--
lack of expertise, security
concerns, resource shortages,
and competing priorities
were listed as the primary ones.
So it goes back to our
story, don't do over-greed.
And if you don't have the
right skills, leverage
a partner as part of the
migration, and hopefully
it will be a successful one.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]